I have a title for today's talk.
I call it slip Damascus's and the fall of the polis and I read that to you
because it's always useful to remember that while we you look back on these
events and know their outcome and can assign to them a special significance
let's never forget.
They didn't know that they were on the brink of the end of the independent polls
and it was very much in fact I'm sure if you if you came along and 362 after
that battle it would never ever occurred to you that that whole fundamental
arrangement of the world that had been sort of in place to some degree perhaps
as far back as the 8th century was going to change its character very sharply
and that although there would still be plays that would be going on it might
seem in the same old way even after the Macedonian conquest.
The fact was that none of them ever again really was autonomous in the sense of
to be fully in control of its own fate both in terms of the internal
constitution and also more importantly or at least the one that was most in
danger the capacity to engage in international relations freely and to be free
to make their own foreign policy.
So as I say it's going to be a very major change but it's something that they
don't know.
They're in the middle of watching well.
In 359
man called Philip became king of Macedonia Macedon which is we know where the
Macedonians were fundamentally Greeks.
That is to say they were Greek speakers and ethnically if you can if there is
such a thing.
They were Greek but they were so far out of the mainstream of the development of
the Greek police that we have been examining this semester that many many Greeks
perhaps most of them didn't think of them as being Greek when Greeks thought
about what it was to be a Greek they thought about more than the fact that they
spoke the Greek language they thought fundamentally if you get to Aristotle you
see how thoroughly true this is it had to do with our culture or way of life and
that way of life was based upon the independent polls.
Well Macedon did not have such a structure Macedon the Greeks called the
Macedonians an ethnic loss a tribal group is what that sort of means something.
We use the words sort of nation somehow to translate ethnic ethnics but it and
that's OK.
The word nation itself remember comes from the Latin word which means to be born
and people who are born of the same stock.
But for the Greeks that it had a different meaning it was people who
participated in the culture that they designated as Hellenic and they thought
the Macedonians fell outside of that there were no place in the Macedonian
kingdom.
It was something that we might call feudal that is to say yes there was a
monarch but there were powerful noblemen who were practically independent and
who owed only a limited allegiance to the king and who were really the dominant
figures in the state for most of the history prior to the appearance of Phillip.
On the other hand the King was an important and powerful character so that you
have this this was true of European feudal states at certain periods in their
development.
On the one hand the fundamental society was based upon great lords great
nobleman barons but there was a king and he was not inconsequential.
That's the situation that obtained in mastodon
in a certain sense.
If a Greek had looked at Macedonian society prior to Philip he might have
described it as Homeric and you'll be familiar with that.
Sure there were guys called vacillates but they were not really the rulers over
the the barons these great King and these great noblemen in their kingdom and
they thought of it as uncivilized in the technical sense if you don't live in a
palace a city as they understood it then you are not civilized you are part of
an ethos and that's the term they used of the tribal societies all around them.
El-Erian Sicilians they were all s from from from an ethnic
the Macedonians on the other hand.
Claimed very proudly and powerfully and insistently that they were Greeks they
were hellions and they probably invented a myth of their descent.
Indeed not merely from Greeks but from the real Greeks.
That is to say the R drives who were the leading people in the time of Homer's
poetry and they they claim direct descent from Agamemnon and the other jive
kings we hear about various Macedonian monarchs of some importance prior to
Philip back at the time of the Persian War.
Alexander the first played an interesting and shady role between the Greeks and
the Persians during the Peloponnesian War we hear of a king paradox who also
played a role shifting between the Spartans and the Athenians.
This business of shifting between sides is not just because they are shifty
people it's that their status is such that they're always vulnerable and not
powerful enough to defend themselves and so they have to make the best deal they
can with whoever has the power at any moment.
One other smart Macedonian king has left a name that we know something about
archeologists who followed predicts one of the things about him was that he kept
a kind of cultural court at his capital and for instance you reporting is for
reasons that we do not know left Athens at some point in the Peloponnesian War
and came to Macedon where he joined the collection of artists and scholars and
whatever that archaeologist was gathering in his kingdom.
Well Philip becomes king in three fifty nine and the Macedonian kings were very
much like Homeric kings as we have described them here.
That is yes you had to have a dynastic claim you had to be a member of the royal
family to be king but that wasn't good enough.
You had to also have a member to rule.
As I said about the Homeric kings if he by by force by power you had to have the
actual capacity to command and that was sometimes you had to demonstrate that by
fighting it out among various potential successors with having the winner come
out as the king.
Something like that is what Philip did.
He was not the most direct descendant of the previous king.
He was left as a kind of a regent over the under aged young King just a boy.
And he was actually Philip's nephew and nephew and Philip's Ward and Philip took
care of him in more senses than one finally killing him and replacing him on the
throne.
That was not a unique event in Macedonian history so Philip is now on the throne
and of course he with this disputed descent.
This is disputed the right to the throne.
You can imagine that he is not in the most secure position when he takes over
this job.
And so I think some part of his actions certainly at the early part of his
career and perhaps all the way through was meant to demonstrate his own
greatness his own his own capacity to be king so as to put down all resistance
internally and for that purpose.
What could be better than spreading the boundaries increasing the power and
making the greatness of Mastodon more than it had been before.
And that's what he undertook it.
It looks as though I think we have enough evidence to believe that he certainly
of course meant to rule Mastodon and to do whatever was necessary however harsh
to make that secure.
But it is pretty clear that he had it in mind to conquer Greece to make himself
the master of Greece.
That was certainly one of his objectives.
As a matter of fact an interesting part of his biography was that as a young man
I mean probably I should say as a boy probably in his teens he was sent to
Thebes as a hostage as a result of a war between the three bands and the
Macedonians.
But he was treated as a as a member of the royal family.
He was treated very decently and with respect and he spent his time in a house
of permanent this.
Can you imagine a better place for young king with his military ambitions to be
brought up than in the House of the man who was surely the foremost general in
the Greece of his time and perhaps of any time.
And I think we should imagine that he must have learned a great deal about
military affairs there.
There remains the question.
Did Philip already have them in his mind the plan of conquering the Persian
Empire which was of course the job that was completed by his son.
Because whatever Philip's intentions may have been he died before he could carry
them out.
And I don't think we can be certain about that but it was an idea that he didn't
have to do a lot to dream up.
I've mentioned to you how many an orator I Socrates most famously had been
calling on various Greek states and individuals to conquer the Persian Empire to
solve Greece's problems.
And he wrote such a letter to Philip once Philip became the most powerful figure
in that world.
And so he certainly could have had the idea that he did have the idea whether he
was planning to do that or not.
We don't know.
Now his first and sort of the instrument that permitted him and mastodon to
become as great as they did was the army that he created.
I mean it is very much he who is the revolutionary the military genius
who creates the weapon which will allow him to conquer Greece and it's the same
military force that enables Alexander the Great who had brought to it who
brought to it brilliant military talents but he had an instrument shaped for him
that was already far and away the best.
Army in the Greek world the best army the Greek world had ever seen perhaps as
good an army is there ever existed in the ancient world.
This is the great achievement of Philip or at least that was the basis of it.
He was not merely a hop like battle leader in the old style
he was his one thing about Philip.
That was very important was his temperament his mind his approach to warfare.
He simply didn't accept the notion of defeat.
He didn't accept the notion of making some kind of a deal except on his terms
when he found it necessary to do so.
He's famous for having said after a temporary setback against one of his
opponents.
Philip has said I have not fled.
But I have retired as RAMS do in order that I may might make a stronger attack
the next time and that he he really lived that principle.
Nobody ever defeated him permanently.
If he had to accept a temporary setback he immediately went to work to repair it
through a variety of means military diplomatic and whatever else he had
available
but as I'm saying at the moment he crafted this great grand new army supplied
led and organized quite differently from what I have described to you in the
past as the standard Greek practice which was essentially the hop life phalanx
and as you know in the course of the Peloponnesian War in the fourth century no
new gimmicks were added to that and different devices were contributed to it but
still what.
That was true.
Now Philip absorbed all the things that had been going on before his time.
But he also made fundamental changes in the way that things work.
Through his failings and of I was going to say of grim professional soldiers now
that I think is in itself an enormously important thing.
We have something new on the Greek scene an army which is a national army.
It is to say it is made up of Macedonians serving Macedon under a Macedonian
king.
But they are not the citizen soldiers that we have examined in the case of the.
The police and its failings.
Their hot plates and that.
They were professional soldiers so that their full time job was being an army.
They did not spend their spare time back on farms.
That means Philip had to pay them a salary for them to perform at the same time.
They were not a mercenary army in the traditional sense.
They were not people gathered anywhere who fought for whoever hired them.
They were very much Macedonian soldiers something we can understand the United
States today.
An unusual thing in American history beginning only a couple of decades ago.
We have that sort of an army.
We have professional national army and I think this is an objective statement.
It has become the best army in the world.
There are many reasons for that but I would argue one reason is that if you can
have the sociological background to permit that kind of an army you are in very
good shape indeed.
And that's what Phillip was able to create the kind of loyalty the kind of
commitment that kind of association with the cause that only a citizen or a
subject of a king can have along with the skill and the practice and the
conditioning that is part of being a professional soldier.
So.
So he has this failings made up of these professionals that I'm talking about.
But he added to that.
A group of people called the foot companions peds at Tai Roy is the Greek word.
Who were the biggest and the strongest of all the Macedonians.
And to that group he added the companion cavalry the head high ROI themselves
the companions of the King.
And of course these with a nobleman and they became personally attached to fill
up in a special way and with the most effective the most reliable forces that he
had an elite corps.
And here again is something different.
The cavalry will play a much more important role in fighting than it ever has in
the Greek fighting of the past.
One of the great geniuses of Phillip would be to create a combined force that
could use cavalry and infantry and some other subordinate forces I'll tell you
about in a minute jointly together to carry out a rather complex military plan
these of course are these these are high ROI are aristocratic horsemen heavily
armor on strong horses.
That's very important as well because if you're going to use them as shock
troops which he did on many an occasion all of that has to be in place.
Then there was a another contingent of infantry with probably less body armor
than his phalanx had hoped.
What called the shield bearers high pass pistols and they occupied the center of
the Macedonian line next to the flags.
These fellows were usually the first infantry forces to follow behind a cavalry
charge if that's the way Phillips fought the battle charging the cavalry at the
enemy.
And as the enemy provided opportunities these shield bearers these lighter
lighter armed infantrymen would find their way and expand the holes opening the
way for the major blow to be struck by the failings of
I'm describing one kind of battle that could be fought.
The thing about having this kind of varied military force is that you can have
different tactics for different battles and they do.
And Philip does things differently on different occasions.
And there is this group of hype hype asbestos or lighter infantry provide a
crucial link between the first mounted attack and the follow up by the Phalanx
proper so you have a minimum star on top of all of this.
You have a professional corps again.
They're all Macedonians remember made up of really light infantry.
That is to say slingers archers javelin men in the traditional mode that the old
Greek armies had but didn't make too much use of typically.
And so that rounds out that composite army group made up of these different
kinds of forces and these
missile men I guess you could call them up supplied both preliminary bombardment
with the things they did to help harass the enemy failings but also they provide
a kind of crucial Reserve support if you need to throw some forces into a
suddenly important piece of the battle.
These guys were very mobile and you could order them into that place to support
whatever was going on there.
You can see how infinitely more complex this was than the kind of fighting we've
talked about before.
Now these Macedonian contingents I've been describing do not represent a
fragmentation of forces as might possibly be thought.
But rather a sort of a diversification and a sophistication of arms.
As one historian puts it a symphony not a cacophony of professionally equipped
men.
Philip's contribution to the history of Western warfare therefore is not so much
tactical as it is organizational creating this complex complex organization that
could have a variety of tactical uses
now.
At first the equipment and the tactics of his Macedonian phalanx for itself did
not differ considerably from the traditional hop light columns of the Greeks.
But he then subsequently made a very important change.
Now he does keep the spear the pike.
That was the fundamental weapon of the the old failings but it was lengthened
from being let's say roughly 8 feet long to 14 feet or so.
Now you cannot hold a 14 foot pike with one hand.
This is a two handed weapon.
If you're going to control and use it effectively that's what you have to do
because you're gonna have two hands on this thing you can't have that hop light
shield.
That was the characteristic of the old Half-Life failings so the shield shrank
and became unimportant.
You realize that once you do this to your hop light phalanx it can only function
successfully as an aggressive force.
If you see what I mean you can't just take blows.
You have to be delivering blows all the time.
The Greens and the breast plates and the heavy headgear were replaced either
with leather which was lighter or very various composite materials or else
abandoned altogether.
So you can see these hot lights don't look anything like the hot lights we're
accustomed to.
The central idea however of the fighting of a fighting mass of infantrymen
remained predominant in fact integrated with and protected by such diverse
forces Phillips phalanx of true Pike men their lances now allowed the first
five.
Not merely the first three ranks to strike at the enemy was both more lethal and
more versatile than the traditional pop like the historian plebeians who wrote
in the second century B.C..
But you have to realize he was a contemporary of Macedonian soldiers who were
still fighting in fundamentally in the same way that Phillip had created.
So he knew what he was saying.
He for instance he describes the great battles between the Romans and the
Macedonians that occurred late in the third and into the second century.
So you even saw he even saw or certainly knew about.
The new failings the Macedonian failings tackling the Roman legion and fighting
it practically to a standstill.
Libya says that infantry who faced such a storm of spears as he puts it might
have as many as ten iron points concentrated on each man.
Nothing him Polonius concluded can stand up to the Phalanx the Romans but the
Roman by himself with his sword can either slash down or break through the ten
spears that all at once pressed against him.
Well he has to face the fact that the Roman legion did defeat one of these
phalanx as in the course of the third century.
But I think if you look at the details you realize it wasn't nothing inevitable
about that defeat.
Circumstances in battle allowed the Romans to win because it put a premium on
the great advantage that the.
Legion had over the failings namely that it was divided up into smaller fighting
units that could adjust and move about the field much more freely than the
fighters in the phalanx of the Macedonians.
That was certainly an edge that the Legion had but there never was a time when a
legion fighting a good Macedonian failings could predict that it would win much
less than it would be any kind of a walkover.
Of course against the kind of forces that Philip faced.
It was all the more likely to produce a Macedonian victory because those were
not Roman legions that they had to face.
Now if you're going to have a national mercenary army a national army made up of
professionals that means it costs money.
In a way that the old failing system did not require the expenditure of funds
very much.
And so Philip early in his career had to gain control of sources of money.
And he did some
early as king.
He immediately had to put down his opponents from within Macedonia.
But he also.
Did what I suppose Macedonian Kings always had to do on their accession.
They were surrounded by what the Greeks called barbarian peoples and these
barbarian peoples were always fighting against the Macedonians and trying to
push back their frontiers and so on.
So Philip turned against these the Olympians and various other peoples and did
an excellent job of defeating them driving them back establishing the boundaries
where he wanted them in the process accomplishing two very important things.
One was to establish his credentials as a great general and leader for internal
purposes and for military purposes is in the sense of winning the confidence of
his soldiers but also
it meant that his own stature in general and the reputation that he gained both
among enemies and friends grew.
And finally the last point he this kind of fighting allowed him to train his
army and to create this army and to make it as excellent as it became before he
had a face more formidable forces than these.
So now he has won the loyalty of his nobility to a degree that no predecessor
ever had.
He now has these barons who are so independent.
Happily gladly serving him and being rather in awe of him.
And the Army in general was devoted to him in a way that was unprecedented for
the Macedonians now with this weapon largely forged he was able to begin serious
expansion in the.
Greek world.
A critical step rather early in his
monarchy was his attack on AM simple as and you will remember and fabulous.
Was this Athenian colony that was such a big deal for the Athenians that they
were prepared to do almost anything to get it back.
But they never had thoroughly been able to get it back until recently.
And so now he took out simplest what was more important than anything for him
was it who held out for Palace was likely to hold mount pan GM which is right
near and fabulous which contain gold and silver mines that were producing wealth
as they had been for centuries now.
And now that wealth was going into Philip's pocket and he used it for the
purpose that was most important chiefly for supply paying for that army that I
have been talking about we are told that this produced about a thousand talents
a year for Phillip's use that that's about the same amount that the Athenians
got out of their empire.
So you are talking about lots and lots of money.
And this explains the economic capacity that gave Philip the chance to use the
kind of army he had.
But he was extraordinarily skillful at the game of diplomacy.
I say game because he treated it in that way.
It was a diplomacy I think for him was an extension of military forces by
peaceful means.
It's kind of a standing clause of its definition of war on its head.
Who was it.
Sir John Fortescue I think it was in the 15th century this defined a diplomat as
a man sent to lie abroad for his country.
I think the spirit behind that pun was certainly right fulfilling that for him.
Diplomacy was a way for advancing his country's interests by whatever means that
he possibly could.
He was very good.
And one of his very great skills was precisely to lie in a very convincing
manner.
And of course it's much easier to get people to believe what you say if you have
got the strongest army anywhere in sight in case you should be so impolite as to
say you're a liar.
I think that must have assisted him.
But what I mean is Philip would say he come into into a conflict with some
policy or some place over some territory that was in dispute or whatever and
they would say Philip what are you trying to do.
You seem to be trying to conquer this trade.
Oh no no no.
Philip said I have.
I have absolutely no no interest in this territory.
I've got other things to do that much more important those proteins in my
background require my attention.
And when the other guys would calm down he would commonly take the place that he
had left alone.
I'm reminded and I guess.
After the Second World War.
In fact even before there was some scholars who made the analogy between Hitler
and Philip and the Boston keys and Churchill.
It's not the worst one.
It's very imperfect but it's not the worst analogy possible.
But remember Hitler kept saying before his strength was great enough simply to
launch a major work he would say if you give me this that's all I'm interested
in.
That is absolutely my last territorial demand in Europe.
And then in a few months he would then seize Austria or something like that.
So Philip reminds me of that.
Because he did such things from time to time.
It said there's just too much to tell in terms of the detail of his career.
But let me just hit a few highlights and give you the direction in which it was
going.
The first.
Business that he had to do after he gain and fifth place and the wealth of the
mines was to gain control of the shoreline of the northern Aegean Sea.
And that meant of course his own Mastodon Macedonia which he had but also
eastward into the region of threats.
And he began precisely to gain control in those places.
It was in 357 that he took and simplest and that meant that he had to clash with
Athens.
Because as I say Athens had never given up its claim to him fabulous and kept
trying to get it back because of its value to the Athenians.
But we will see is war between Philip and Athens on and off.
Until the final victory of Macedonia.
It's.
A period of quite a stretch of time in the year in which that's going on.
On the other hand it's never a full scale war with Philip trying to conquer
Athens how could he.
He's still outside from a territorial point of view outside the entire old Greek
world but they can he can cause all the havoc he wants to.
In the northern Aegean and the Athenians will be unhappy about it.
They will send forces up into that part of the world to contest Philip's
expansion and that's where the fighting goes on.
But the Athenians are not ready to take him on and really try to stop him from
going where he seems to be going.
What they do is they respond when he does something that annoys them or that
they're worried about.
Sometimes they go out and fight him but usually they don't.
Or sometimes they do and they do so too little and too late.
That's the story of the relationship between these two powers.
Throughout this whole stretch of time
with the expansion of Phillip in a variety of directions he increases his
revenues wherever he conquers Cecily gets down into Sicily.
Now we're talking about territory that the Greeks consider to be Greece.
And Philip is now gaining more and more control of that area.
Revenues grow and he even builds a navy and begins to challenge Athens and
others at sea.
He attacks Athenian commerce when he is in.
When he is quarrelling with the Athenians if he in position in general is badly
weakened in the years between 357 and 355 in what the traditional historians
calls the social war.
That doesn't mean that a fight they fought over tea cups or anything like that
social derives from the Latin word Saki which means allies.
It was a rebellion against the allies of Athens in the theme in Confederation
which
really frightened the Athenians and kept them busy putting it down for a couple
of years.
There is some debate among scholars today as to how oppressive or not was the
Athenian rule of its empire.
The reason more recent scholarship has suggested that the Athenians were not
really very oppressive which leaves four I think for them an uncomfortable
question.
If that's true why was there this rebellion in the years three fifty five.
We just don't know enough to talk details about this but I think there can be no
mistake.
The Athenians abused their position of power and leadership in the Empire.
They didn't do so as thoroughly and completely as they did in the great Athenian
Empire of the 5th century.
But that was largely because they couldn't they never had the power they never
had the.
Financial strength to be able to impose their will as the earlier empire had.
But they did what they could and they did enough to annoy their allies into such
a rebellion.
Athens recovers they win they put down the Allied rebellion but they are
weakened in the process and 356 there breaks out on the mainland of Greece what
they call the sacred war.
It's the old business of who controls the Delphic Oracle the neighbors foxes and
locusts.
Frequently take advantage of opportunities to gain control of the Oracle and to
deprive the priests of their control of the region.
The priests then call on other Greeks traditionally led by Sparta but not always
to beat up the people who have taken over the oracles place and drive them out
and restore it to the priests.
Well this is another in that theory.
In that series of events Thebes and forces are involved in a war over Delphi the
fashion general.
The only time it crops up in this story on a mark is apparently was an
outstanding military leader and defeated the thieves and even pushed into
fiercely.
And that brings Philip into the picture because Philip has been expanding
Macedonian power into Sicily from the north coming south.
And so Philip takes his forces and he pushes the oceans back defeats and Marcus
sends them off.
Now here's the question is this a good or bad for the Greeks.
On the one hand the once thought would be well sure he's just put down this
fellow who has arrogantly seized the Delphic oracle but now who is there who is
sitting in testily this great big new army.
Is he going to be a menace to the Greeks in general.
Well we who have had a chance to know how it came out and know that it did.
But at the time.
People were divided.
Some to.
Oh my heavens.
This is a thoroughly aggressive man at the head of an army that looks incredibly
strong and he has terrific ambitions.
What are we going to do against those who said no it's ok he's he's OK.
Now he's happy.
He doesn't want to do any more than that.
Let's take a look at Athens.
Who will mess which will necessarily be the leading figure in the opposition to
Philip such as it is Thebes.
Last time we looked at thieves thieves had reached a position of power perhaps
greater than that of Athens.
But you remember the deaths of plop at us and a permanent US simply did not
allow thieves to continue to have that vitality and power that it had before.
It's still a very strong state.
It's it's hotplate phalanx it's still formidable they still have great ambitions
and so on.
But it turns out they don't really have the capacity to take the lead in such a
business.
The Athenians do and they are very much concerned about what's happening but
it's not the same Athens that we saw in the height of its power in the fifth
century relatively speaking.
It is a very poor place indeed.
It is however still the number one naval power in the Greek world and therefore
very important.
Let's take a look at the internal life of Athens a little bit.
Notice some changes they will have some significance in terms of what decisions
the Athenians make.
There was something that was introduced.
We don't know just when it might have been late in the Peloponnesian War.
It might have been afterwards.
It is called the Theo Ric fund.
And what that is it gets its name apparently because there was a a payment to
the Athenian citizens of the price necessary to pay for the ticket to see the
great theatrical festivals twice.
That went on twice a year in Athens which had apparently degenerated pretty much
into a door into a kind of a welfare fund for the very poor.
It did not amount to a stunning amount of money but given the poverty of Athens
in general any fund of money could be very significant.
At critical moments especially on issues of national defense.
But there was a lot of argument in sort of the Democratic Party the party of the
underprivileged or whatever always insisted that everybody supposed to keep
hands off of the art fund which should only be used for its welfare state.
I am back.
I'm embarrassed to use such a term because of course there's nothing like that
in the ancient world.
I'm just for that portion of the of the national income that was used to
alleviate the worst poverty.
They wanted that on touch.
But when the state was under siege it was under threat was in had to go to war.
So it seemed to some politicians they needed the money to do it and say let's
take this the ORIC fund for now while we have this necessity.
And there'd be a fight about that.
Remember the Athenian Empire in the 5th century.
Never had a money not never but could generally handle its money problem because
they've had this great income from the Empire say roughly a thousand towns a
year coming in that was not true.
So that if Athens wanted to send an expedition anywhere they had to levy a
direct war tax it was called the ACE for RA.
They had done so two or three times during the Peloponnesian War.
So far as we know they had never done it before that time.
We've stressed how unnatural direct taxation was in the Greek world.
But here that's what they really had.
They had to pay this ace Farrar if they were going to conduct a military and
naval campaigns that they felt were necessary.
In fact they used to be true that individual Greeks back in the 5th century
could pay their share of what was assigned to them for the ACE Farrar
individually.
But now there were so few people who could do that that they organized groups of
tax payers whom they called symmetries who would share the burden.
It makes me think that it probably sank further down the sort of the wealth
class of Athens more people I guess we're now paying taxes than before.
In the first century the only people who pay taxes were the very wealthy.
And now that I think was attenuated as people who were not so wealthy had to pay
something as well.
And another thing is that we find the Athenians using as a regular thing in
these campaigns that they will have to fight mercenary soldiers.
And I don't mean mercenaries of the Macedonian kind of the kind that Phillip was
using.
I mean hiring a band of mercenaries who might come from any place in Greece.
And that was because the Athenians were reluctant themselves to go out on
expeditions and nothing could be more different.
I think from the way the Athenians behaved in the 5th century when they were all
over the joint as you remember in 457 that inscription that talked about those
who died from one tribe all over the map they were proud of it and they never
ran short of soldiers willing to do this kind of thing.
The assembly voted it and the people will not and not now the Athenians are
reluctant to engage in these activities.
Neither they're our main source for complaint about this is the master and his
who much of the time is pleading with the Athenians to recognize the danger
presented by Philip.
And for them to take the necessary steps to check Philip before it was too late
and what he asked them to do repeatedly was to first of all vote the money that
was necessary to support the expedition and then not to hire mercenaries but to
serve themselves in the fighting.
And he did not win those arguments very often.
There were in Athens throughout this period people that we would call in our own
jargon hawks and doves people who were ready to fight.
For these purposes and people who were very reluctant to do so.
The.
The people who seemed to be the most reluctant to do this were the upper classes
of course because war meant taxation and they were going to do the bulk of the
pain of the taxes it may well be I don't want to make too much of this.
Philip wherever he could.
Would install oligarchic governments in places that he ruled he was not
interested in democracy.
He was not a friend of democracy.
There were some Athenians who had never given up their hope that an oligarchy
could be placed into Athenian into Athens instead of a democracy.
They would have been doves and more.
I mean there is a pretty clear indication that Philip did in Athens what he did
in other states as well.
He bribed important Athenians to be champions of his cause and the people it's
easiest to get this to work with our people who agree with your approach we're
on your side of the argument.
So there was some of that
and I mean there was a real difference of opinion as there always is that we
should be very aware of it.
In recent years this is the kind of thing you see some people in society seeing
a great danger out there that must be prepared for and confronting others
thinking that that is overblown that that is too pessimistic.
That there is no such great danger or that it can best be dealt with by
negotiation and conversation and anything but fighting.
And that was the situation in Athens.
You could if you were hostile if you were a member of the Hawk faction you would
say your opponents were deluding themselves about the degree of the danger and
that Phillip was a very special kind of a menace.
If you were a dove you would accuse your opponents of being alarmists
excessively afraid and worse.
Of course both both sides accused each other of much worse things having to do
with their characters and so on.
As people always do.
The first statement we have of DeMoss the NIS who will emerge as the dominant
hawk for most of the time that he is doing business in Athens is in 351 when he
delivers the speech that we call the first Filipic.
He delivered a series of speeches attacking Philip and warning the Athenians of
the danger presented by Philip to this day Filipic is a word in English which
means a strong attacking piece of rhetoric against some individual or some
nation.
He charged the Athenians with having created the great danger that they faced by
making Phillip into a great man through neglect by their refusal to stop him
when it was relatively easy to do so.
They should send.
He thought a fleet of good sized fleet to serve in the northern Aegean Sea and
to stop Philip's expansion and to stop Philip period.
He urged them and he will do this over and over again.
Don't hire mercenaries enlist for service yourself.
Vote a war tax.
And those of you who should pay it should do so.
He lost the argument.
The Athenians did not take that action that he recommended Philip.
Pretty soon after that attacked.
The old Lindsey ends you remember.
This is an important state on the Charles civic peninsula.
It has been a very significant state back in this century.
You remember when the Spartans went up there to defeat the Olympians so it
constructed a league of their own.
Well they weren't out of business yet so Philip went after them.
And again.
What's his name.
Damascus's urges the Athenians to get involved and to prevent Philip from taking
all Leonsis and the shell Citic states and gaining control of the Northern GNC
and all the danger that that presented to Athenian interests.
Again he loses the argument.
He delivers three Olympic speeches which have the same character as the one I've
described.
But the Athenians do not do it in the year 348 Oh Leonsis falls
the other in that city and the other cities of the region were destroyed.
And you remember this is not a typical way in which the Greeks dealt with
defeated states although heaven knows the Peloponnesian War had seen examples of
it but it was a very very harsh.
Kind of warfare that Phillip carried forward.
He destroyed the cities physically enslaved what was left of the population.
And so this was a message I think he wasn't just that he had a cruel
temperament.
Well I suppose he must have had that too but it was meant to be exemplary.
It was meant to say when Philip says Do this do it.
Because then he if you don't he will crush you and this is what will happen to
your city and to you that's an old technique.
You know that we know that the Assyrians used to do that way back in biblical
times in which they would deliberately be as brutal and cruel as they could be.
And having done so would broadcast how brutal and cruel they had been in order
to encourage other states to behave appropriately in the future.
Hitler had used those same tactics early in the Second World War when he
destroyed the city of Rotterdam from the air completely not military whatsoever.
It was obviously intended to terrify everybody who might want to resist him.
So that's what Phillip did up there.
Finally after further fighting of one kind or another the Athenians and a number
of other Greeks make a treaty with Phillip.
It is called a piece of flock guarantees.
He was one of the negotiators on the Athenian team.
There really didn't seem to be much disagreement among the Athenians as to the
desirability of this piece.
Even the Acehnese who is normally opposed to anything like it felt that it
probably had to be done and I think that just reflected the realities of the
distribution of power and also of the willingness of the Athenians to do
anything more than that.
And so there is this period of the piece of alacrity in which the Athenians make
a defensive alliance with fellow and there at things said when another
development raises the.
Panic Button I think for the mass armies and some others
the sacred war is another sacred war going on.
This time the people who want to restore power to the priests invite Phillip to
lead the Greek forces in the sacred war.
That is a very big deal.
First of all it recognizes the Macedonians as Greeks in the truest sense of the
world word it should have been probably was a major source of satisfaction.
For Phillip and an extraordinary glory in the eyes of his fellow Macedonians
that the Greeks should have done was not only accepted them as Helen's but ask
them to save the oracle of Apollo the center of Greek worship their
so he takes his army runs into the ocean blasts the fallen Army and does what he
was asked to do in the process when it's all over he decides that from now on
Macedon and King Philip will take not just one vote on the council that governs
the Delphic oracle.
I may have mentioned it to you earlier in the semester the fact the monarch
Council Council of those who dwell around Delors I mean Delphi.
He took two votes on that council and he made himself president of the pithy and
games.
You remember these pan hellenic festivals they were for great pan holiness
festivals Olympia NEMA the Isthmus of cards and the one at Delphi which was
called a pithy and games.
And here is this barbarian from Macedonia not only sitting on the council but
being the chairman holding the position of honor as all the Greeks gathered for
the pithy end games.
Well.
This must have had an enormously intimidating effect on many in the Greek world.
And it becomes more and more Athens that has to take the lead.
If anybody is going to resist the Athenians were concerned at least those who
were not determined to accept the course of events and Philip was very careful
with Athens.
For this there was a very good reason it had a special strategic set of
advantages that nobody else in the Greek world had.
And that Philip didn't have an easy answer for Athens was a walled city which
had proven itself capable of defending those walls and you should realize that
up to this point in Greek history nobody has demonstrated any kind of ability of
taking a walled city by force.
The only way you can take a walled city is by surrounding it and starving it
out.
But you remember now that the Athenians have a navy and walls they can't be
starved out in the same way.
So taking on Athens if you really want to take the city is a job that's very
difficult indeed.
And of course the Athenians have their navy which makes that true but also
allows the Athenians to do you harm in a way that other states cannot do.
So all of that means that Phillip is not about to make a headlong assault on
Athens but to try to have his way by going around Athens somehow.
He tried to win the Athenian support through his usual technique of soft words
explaining how he had no
aggressive intentions in areas that the Athenians were interested in even though
he had already demonstrated that that wasn't right.
And also by working Athenian politics by bribing Athenian politicians to be on
his side and using every device he could to make it harder for the hawkish
people to have their way to master means from here on in is determined and
determinedly against fellow spending all his energy and time trying to get up
Athenian support and then indeed to put together a coalition of states besides
Athens to resist and fight and defeat felt.
And indeed he is more successful than he was before because the danger from
Phillip is obviously greater so that more Athenians can see it that way.
The league he puts together includes you be a mega a at Kani Mia Lucas forces
and finally Thebes and that's a pretty good trick forces and thieves are
traditional opponents but they're both in the league and what that tells you is
that those states and especially those states which are in central Greece
closest to where Filip is located with his forces in the facility and so they
now see that there is a great danger from him and they join in an anti Phillip
coalition
he doesn't go at them immediately directly.
He goes to war but he does so.
Up in the north on the shores of the Aegean Sea he moves eastward.
This is an enormously clever thing to do.
Towards what the Greeks call the cursed Jesus the peninsula which we call the
Gallipoli Peninsula.
The hellish spot Philip wants to gain control of that because if you can control
Inc.
Can Control the helos upon the old story he can cut off trade.
He can starve Athens out and it would hurt others too.
But Athens would be the main attack.
And so he moves forces to the Iranian coast taking various cities there and
gaining more and more territory towards that end.
And then he goes all the way across to the Bosphorus to Byzantium modern
Istanbul.
And he takes that city as well.
And of course you can cut off trade if you can control the Bosphorus.
So this is very very serious for Athens.
And it's on this occasion that the master needs deliverance is his third Filipic
making the same case as he has been making all along and only doing so I think
he's been even greater intensity and this time with more persuasiveness because
more and more Athenians understand how serious this menace has become a small
point but not so trivial that the Athenians were able even to enlist the support
in language at least by Persia if the Athenians the Greeks are going to fight
this guy would be awfully handy if you could get the Persians support.
As it turns out the Persians don't do anything of importance in resisting
Phillip.
But it's a.
It shows you how the master of these and those Greeks who agreed with him were
attempting to put together a strong coalition as they could to try to stop him.
Forgive me I just don't pay too much attention to what I'm saying but I'm
constantly being being reminded of the behavior of the European states just
prior to the second world war and in place of Persia.
I think we would have to put the United States of America which was out of the
game and sort of constantly trying to stay out of the game powerful isolationist
sentiment in this country and people in Europe some people urging that
everything be done to get the United States into the game and others reluctant
to do that.
It wouldn't make any difference.
Nothing would have gotten the Americans to take an active part against Hitler at
that time.
And I suspect there was no chance that anybody could have convinced the Persians
to do anything at this point point either
but the Athenians do send the force and it's a good sized force and it does a
very good job and they drive Phillip back out of some of the places that he has
conquered which I think is interesting to think about.
It's not obvious that if the Athenians had gotten their coalition together
earlier and if they had done the best they could it's not obvious that they
couldn't have defeated Phillip.
You know there's this terrible danger that we will all become victims of a fait
accompli what happened obviously had to happen it couldn't happen any other way.
No I don't think that's right.
We don't certainly don't live our lives as though that's true and we shouldn't
allow ourselves to imagine it's true in retrospect the fact that the Athenians
could have such success against Phillip as they did at this moment is evidence
that that was by no means a hopeless cause
once again a sacred war breaks out over Delphi again the safety sonically this
time of course or having as its president Philip invite Phillip to lead the
forces of the Sacred War the sacred war has been declared against the town near
Delphi called an officer and that's the force that he's going to use against it
Philip moves down from Cecilie arrives at a place not very far from Delphi
called LRT on one side and the other side at Thermopylae.
These these are the routes to get down into central Greece.
Once you go through those places you are.
Right next to be sure you are a couple of days from Athens you're right in the
middle of a position where you could do terrific harm
when the Athenians receive the news.
There really is panic from the masses tells the story.
Now.
The master NIS is a witness who is excellent because he is a participant
contemporary.
That's great.
But he you've got to look at him with a certain amount of skepticism because
he's a participant.
He's a guy who held a certain point of view.
He was very active in politics.
He has strong views on everything his reputation depends upon how you look upon
what he did.
So that you must understand that when he tells us these things he's telling it
from his perspective it's very much like Winston Churchill's histories of the
two world wars in which he played a very large part even in the first.
But certainly in the second and it's not that he lies it's not that he deceived.
But when you read those stories you read them as Winston Churchill sees them and
you have to be alert to them.
There's a wonderful nothing about Churchill's wonderful story apparently true
that when when Churchill's book on the first world war came out.
Let's I forget the title but it's let's say it was called The Great War which it
was
the former prime minister Arthur Balfour who didn't like Churchill at all.
It's supposed to have said I see that Winston has published another book about
himself and called it the Great War.
The enemies of the Muslims might say the same things about what he says in some
of his speeches.
But later on in his career when there was a big battle between him and his chief
opponent
his friends most of his friends were asking the Assembly to vote him a crown.
It meant a crown of leaves not a goal but the honor for things he had done for
Athens and his opponents thought that you know what should be done for the
Muslims for what he had done Athens is to throw them off the Acropolis so that
it was a great debate that we have both hands up and it's in that debate that he
recounts the things he has done for Athens why they should be grateful to him
and this moment is one he points to.
He tells about the news came to light came to Athens that that Filip was in L.A.
in and he says we all gathered there first thing in the morning and the place
was full.
If you remember that passage I read to you from Aristophanes about how things
usually were in the Athenian assembly.
It became ambling in late.
No no probably nobody was in a hurry.
No he says and everybody was was there and when the uh brittany for the day the
president the meeting said came to that point we said who wishes to speak no
one.
No one raised their hand
and then I got up and gave you guys the good advice that followed all that stuff
but but I think we can't doubt the s the central truth of the situation that
there was just a terrible fear and no idea how to cope the masses then you know
suggested what steps should be taken to resist one of them.
And he was able to do it now.
It was to use that the Ark Fund to supply the forces that were necessary.
Secondly to do something that was quite an achievement from a diplomatic point
of view to make an alliance with themes ever since the late three 70s Athens had
not been allied to Thebes it had become alarmed that Seaborn power and a joined
even with Sparta against the Thebes.
But here as we're into the very late forties early three thirties he makes an
alliance with Thebes so that what is surely the strongest ground force on the
side of the Greeks against Phillip will be there namely the Seabees and the the
big oceans and general
finally in 338 the battle of Crimea takes place in Western B ocean
and the result is a victory for
the battle itself was by no means a walkover.
It was very close our accounts of it make it clear that there was every
possibility even then even though the Spartans weren't there even though
Phillips forces were at their peak the Greeks might have won that battle.
That's a very important thing to remember.
But they didn't fill up one and that was the end of Greek freedom.
Thereafter the states all had to bow down to Philip in terms of foreign policy.
In many cases he actually interfered in their internal autonomy.
He established garrisons at key places in the Greek world including Karl Case in
Nubia cards and outran ratio in the West.
And they were called the fetters of Greece.
It was like you put a great chain across Greece to show and demonstrate and make
real his control.
Athens was forced to abandon the Confederacy that its own Confederacy they were
forced to make an alliance with Phillip.
He constituted in 336 the league of Corinth with himself as president.
It was an offensive and defensive alliance.
Phillip was commander in chief and he could tell everybody what to do and they
would have to do it.
This truly was the end of Greek freedom.
As it turned out Philip was assassinated in the same year so that he never was
able to demonstrate how he would carry on.
Once he had that power the business of the conquest of Persia.
If that was in the mind of Philip had to be left to his very young son Alexander
who I think was 18 at this point
so that gets us to the interesting question of history's judgment on these
events and especially I think the interesting person is the masses.
And as you read in your problems collection the 19th century German historian
droids in and the Germans historians of that time in general had no doubt about
the judgment.
It was very negative about the master.
After all what was Athens anyway according to Joyce and it was I'm advocating
the republic the lowest blow anybody could deliver a republic of lawyers.
And what the master needs was trying to preserve was client that the high the
the world of small independent states a contemptible term and in the eyes of
Joyce and his fellow nationalists.
Germany you remember had just was I forget the date of his writing either we had
already been unified by
Bismarck or there were nationalists were demanding that these little states all
be brought together into a great German Empire.
And that's what Joyce then was.
The future draws then said was with fellow de Marston is was a reactionary
trying to retain things that were whose time has come and gone.
What was needed was the unification of the ancient Mediterranean and this was a
step in that direction.
Why was it necessary to have a unification of the ancient Mediterranean as would
finally be accomplished not by Philip and Macedon but by the Romans because it
was all part of the great plan without which there could not have been
Christianity
Christianity could come to the world and dominate Europe because it had been
made into a single world by virtue of the Macedonian Roman conquest and master
knees and his small minded petty way was standing in the way of that
yes there were Admiral bobble things about the mass armies but his behavior and
his policy was quixotic because it was hopeless.
And I think this is my reading of what the Roisin really is saying he lost.
So he must have been wrong.
Winners are always right or else they wouldn't win.
Now I think we can evaluate that in a different way.
If we think about a different situation I've been thinking about it all along
and telling you about it which is let's take a look at Winston Churchill who has
been called by historians that the master needs of that time the man who had
been calling attention to the danger from Hitler and trying to rally support and
really treated like an idiot until finally the knife the dagger was at the
throat of the British.
And only then and with great reluctance did the British put him in control.
Now if we look at his experience and what he did I think it's illuminating the
difference between a heroic victory and disaster can be terribly thin taking
office at a low point in the fortunes of his country and its allies.
Churchill.
Made a famous speech which just breathed defiance when there was no physical
justification for such a position.
He said this I have myself full confidence that if all do their duty if nothing
is neglected.
And if the best arrangements are made as they are being made we shall prove
ourselves once again able to defend our island home to ride out the storm of war
and to outlive the menace of tyranny if necessary for years if necessary alone.
We shall go on to the end we shall fight in France we shall fight on the seas
and the oceans we shall fight with growing confidence and growing strength in
the air and we shall defend our Island whatever the cost may be we shall fight
on the beaches we shall fight on the landing grounds we shall fight in the
fields and in the streets and we shall fight in the hills we shall never
surrender
and yet England came within a hair's breadth of losing that war.
And suffering the horrors of invasion and occupation by Nazi Germany in fact
that Hitler and Goering continued bombing the RAAF landing fields and ground
facilities as they began to do with the Battle of Britain.
Instead of.
Turning away from that using their planes to bomb cities and scaring civilians
it's very clear to me that Germany would have won the Battle of Britain and
control of the air which would have made their success inevitable.
Now imagine that you've gone that way.
In that case Churchill's bulldog determination his refusal to accept what was a
relatively generous peace offer after the fall of France would seem in
retrospect the wrong headed defiance of a man who brought his people low by his
own intransigence.
He would have been treated I think by history as some kind of a gallant fool
some kind of a brave imbecile
but men like Churchill and the masterminds know that those who love liberty must
fight for it.
Even against all odds even when there is little support even when victory seems
impossible.
In spite of the outcome it seems to me that the sand of Athens and its Greek
allies at Karenga may have been in words that Churchill used in another contest
context their finest hour.
Thank you very much.